by the way you'll be careful what you're
saying now because these guys they're
filming i know
prince william and kate middleton are
taking on a new venture
on wednesday the duke and duchess of
cambridge announced they are launching
their very own youtube channel
and looked super cute together while
doing it by the way you'll be careful
what you say now because these guys
they're filming
[Music]
the royal couple also posted the teaser
on their joint instagram account
with the caption better late than never
and although we don't know very many
details of what their content will
entail
we do know they've been using their
social platforms for community outreach
on wednesday kate celebrated
international day of the midwife
to raise the status and profile of
nursing a cause the couple has been
passionate about especially during the
outbreak of covet 19.
the experiences the frontline workers go
through now is like nothing that anyone
has ever seen
i i would believe a lot of them are
getting on with the job
and making us all very proud by how
their just
their stoicism and their determination
to beat this but it isn't all business
with william and kate
the two have also sprinkled in a lot of
personal moments on social media
the couple recently celebrated their
10th wedding anniversary
sharing some sweet family moments on
instagram writing
we are enormously grateful for the 10
years of support we have received in our
lives as a family
[Music]
they also recently shared some of their
children's milestones
here's princess charlotte looking all
grown up on her sixth birthday
then there's prince louie who just
turned three
[Music]
and we can't forget prince george who's
looking more and more like his dad
as he grows up
[Music]
hello